- But that's such a
classic look, Magnum PI.
I just wanna see that
photo, show everybody again,
remind you of how good this looks.
- [Tom Selleck] Whoa!
- Yeah!
(audience cheering)
There is nothing that says I am truly hot
like a Hawaiian shirt.
Okay. I'm sure that you
know that people love
that Magnum PI look so much,
but they still dress like you.
And actually one of
those people works here,
and her name is Teagan.
So here's this photo.
(Kelly Clarkson and audience laughing)
Look at her trying to like, copy your,
there's Teagan over there.
(Kelly Clarkson laughs and claps)
- Hi Tom.
- See, we love, we love the look.
- I love the mustache.
- Thank you. Thank you!
- [Kelly Clarkson] I know.
- And when puberty hits
it'll really come in full.
- [Kelly Clarkson]
(chuckling) It'll really...
(Teagan laughing)
- I'm telling you, this is,
that's not true for everyone.
I have dated guys,
- I know.
- They can't grow mustaches.
- Some people can't.
- [Kelly Clarkson] It's a gift.
- Ashton Kutcher told me he
couldn't grow a good mustache,
when I worked with him
- I know he has the
boy-ish look thing, right?
- Yeah.
- You got that straight up "I'm a man."
Like it's not, yeah.
- I'm just
- Yeah.
- I'm disappointed that, that
you didn't wear the shorts.
(Kelly Clarkson laughing)
- It was cold and Halloween.
- I got a lot of short
questions, 'cause they're short.
- You know what though?
They, they were short then
back in the day, though,
if you got nice legs.
- Well that's what shorts
are. Shorts are short.
- They are. But...
(audience laughing) (audience clapping)
- And, and those pajama
bottoms that they wore
for about the last decade.
- Yeah.
- Are silly.
- Are they?
- And you, and you can trip on 'em,
and they're, you know what?
- Are they?
- They're coming back up, the shorts.
- They are on some people,
but on others that don't have
maybe the legs for shorts.
- No, no, no they are,
look at the basketball players right now,
the shorts are coming back
to where they should be.
- They're coming up. They're coming.
(Kelly Clarkson and audience laughing)
I love that you're,
like, into short shorts.
- Well.
- This is my, this is
the most fabulous thing
that will happen to me today.
You talking about how we
need to wear short shorts.
- Well I cheated, you know,
if I had a, you know, I read the script
and I knew if I had a
fight scene coming up.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Okay.
- I wouldn't wear the shorts.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- Because I want to put pads
underneath my jeans and stuff,
- Yeah.
- But uh,
- Keep it, keep it safe.
- I, I cheated it that way,
but it's, it's hot over there.
- I'm just saying not everybody
can sport shorts like that.
Well done sir.
- I know that.
(Kelly Clarkson and audience laughing)
Well, I, I played basketball
right up until college when
I actually sat on the bench
at USC, instead of playing all the time.
But uh,
- [Kelly Clarkson] You're
not bitter about it though.
- That happens to athletes.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- But it didn't affect my legs.
- It didn't affect,
they still looked great.
(Kelly Clarkson and audience laughing)
The legs and the mustache, you got it all.
Thank you,
- I should have worn shorts today.
- [Kelly Clarkson] You
should have worn shorts!